blade Smith welcome to the forge on top
of your guys anvils you'll see you have
stacks of 1095 and 15 N20 steel you'll
be using that steel to build Damascus
blades but not your signature style
blades I want you guys to build this
[Music]
this is a nine foot dagger
this isn't enough steel yeah so now
before you guys throw your hands up when
you walk away let me be a little bit
more specific we want you to build a
one-fifth scale replica of this blade so
breakout calculators break out those
measuring tapes every aspect of this
knife needs to be scaled down five times
good luck your time starts now we're
doing a Damascus blade that's a lot of
material and I got to get it up to
temperature so I'm going to get that
stuff cleaned up get it in the Forge and
then when I've got that down time I'll
go take all the measurements off that
big old knife I want something to stand
apart so I'm gonna do a ladder pattern
going above above and beyond
what the rest are doing just in Damascus
I'm trying to get a nice even heat and I
like to use a magnet once you hit
non-magnetic and you'll get a little bit
past that you're usually okay for most
deals
perfect there we go
welding
now that I've got my Billet together I
take a moment get my measurements I got
this steel drawn out I prefer Forge to
finish because if you hand hammer it as
much as you can into shape and then go
to quench it kind of tends to avoid
having as much warpage
there you go all right leave it in there
okay
did Lyle use all of his steel it doesn't
look like it I don't think so
they give me a lot of Steel it's more of
a trip up I think they want you to spend
more time cleaning and welding and
drawing out when you're gonna end up
cutting most of that steel away I
measure the blade I end up coming up
with two and a half inches wide by 12.1
long the Blade's 75 inches 75 divided by
five you got 15 inch blade and shoulders
at about two and a half
now that I got my steel where I want it
I start grinding in my bevels I leave it
thick because with a chop I want to keep
it as thick as I possibly can but it's
also a dagger so you need to have that
diamond shape on both sides I've been at
the grinder a long time this is a really
good time to quench then do your
grinding
there's a quench
if it's not heated right it could crack
or damage your blade
as soon as I pull that blade out of the
oil it's straight I'm very happy with
how it quenched
Lyle's blade to me looks shorter than
any other blade out there bald blade
looks too thin in profile to me three
two one turn off your machines this
round is over all right guys
congratulations you've made it through
round one which means you're going into
round two where you're adding handles to
your blades turning them into fully
functioning weapons good luck your time
starts now for the guard going brass
instead of Steel going after a steel
guard will likely take twice as long to
Route out
I got my guard drilled out and in pretty
good shape now it's time for the ash to
turn into the handle
I have to go back to the drill and work
the drill bit back and forth a little
bit to open up the hole inside the wood
as it'll help secure the handle so I'm
working on my pommel I'm trying to pin
the end on I finally get the peen to
take pretty well but it's still a little
loose which could be enough to send me
home I find the two biggest pieces of
brass that I can and I cut out the
shapes that I need roughly
time is just running away from me here
I actually have a handle yet
I gotta get a move on it
I'm just praying to the knife gods that
I don't pop this piece of handle
material open because I
don't have time to make another one this
is it I get my holes drilled finally
this wave of relief just washes over me
but I haven't got time to feel grateful
I gotta move
I don't have time to thread the pommel I
don't have time to thread the Tang I
don't have any time for that anymore gas
is on I decide that I'm gonna weld
around the back of my Tang
you run the risk of heating up the tank
so much that you actually set the wood
and or epoxy on fire
and good enough is good enough gentlemen
now that I got measurements I need to
move on to my handle
I'm spending time trying to get it
milled out getting a nice tight fit
without splitting my wood
can you tell me what Lyle's working on
and Lyle's cutting out his material for
his handle
the wild bladesmith doing its mating
call my Lyle's putting a thread on his
Tang Once I get the Palm will threaded
on I realize that the Tang's too long
the last thing I want is my Tang to
break off in testing
after I cut it put it all together and I
had a nice tight fit I wish I could take
more time to make things nicer but I
just don't have the time to do that
so at this point I'm going to put two
pins in the handle just for extra
precaution that way I know it's not
going to come apart I could crack the
handle or the bit won't go all the way
through and then I have a hole in my
handle and I can't get a pin in It Holes
go through and I'm just super excited
because now I can start sharpening my
knife
on your tools this round is over Welcome
to our strength test our giant skull
chop
and just to make you guys feel a little
bit more relaxed these are some of the
biggest skulls I've ever chopped into
I'm gonna take your staggers stab and
smash into these skulls repeatedly Lyle
you're up first you ready to go yes sir
foreign
good job your Edge held up great your
handle and guard they're kind of cocked
off to the side not quite an alignment
but nothing came loose good job thank
you
Ben it's always fun for the second guy
isn't it
just do it man
[Music]
I still have a knife well Ben you
survived we do have a few issues we've
got the gapping down here but it didn't
affect anything fortunately one thing
that is an issue is you've got some
serious chipping right here on the one
side
but in blades in one piece good job
thank you
what do you thinking James this is what
we're here for right that's what I'm
here for I know that
oh
my God
you made it James you survived
your blade Edge you didn't lose anything
it still feels very sharp only thing is
your palm oil is a little bit loose but
still feels secure
good job thank you
all right bladespizz this is the
sharpness the sugar cane slice
now in this particular test I will take
your scaled down daggers and try to cut
through these sugar canes now unlike the
strength test this is all about what
your edges do to the sugar cane while
you're first you ready for this yes sir
all right let's talk about your weapon
here your edges over here while this is
an obtuse grind actually cut very
cleanly over also your weapon
we'll cut it thank you
bend your interns are you ready
absolutely
all right Ben let's talk about your
blade here on one side of the blade it
cuts cleanly on the sugar canes but
right here in the spot that you actually
have the jagged chips it actually ripped
the sugar cane but overall sir it'll cut
thank you
all right James your turns are you ready
slice it up sweet
all right James let's talk about your
blade here this has a sweet feel in the
balance you have created with this
particular Blade the only thing is the
pummels still got a little bit loose but
that was already there prior to this
test it is sharp and most importantly
sir
it'll cut
wait Smith you gave us some great work
here but our judges have made a decision
the placement leaving the forge
is Ben
this came down to basically two things
the damage on your blade which was the
only blade that took damage and the fit
up between your guard and pummel
I understand
Ben I want to say thank you for coming
out but unfortunately you might have to
ask you to leave the forge
thanks guys well done man
I'm disappointed because of course I
wanted to see it through to the end man
I'm sure that the edge of the blade that
got chipped got hotter than the rest of
it when it was quenched it was just more
brittle